jamais ce produit n'a été autant
convoité le papier toilette en rouleau a
été inventé aux états unis à la fin du
19e siècle
c'est la bombe perforé qui a fait son
succès il n'est arrivé en france qu'au
début des années 1960 en remplacement du
papier journal
sans entrer dans les détails son succès
tient également à sa capacité
d'absorption qui est elle même est liée
au phénomène de capillarité le papier
toilette est constitué de fibres de
cellulose entremêlées les molécules qui
la composent et les molécules d'eau
sakhir mutuellement
du coup l'eau remonte entre les fibres
comme le café dans un morceau de sucre
vous voyez le papier toilette c'est
hygiénique et physique et c'est une
vraie capsule 2d confiné aller à demain
et surtout n'oubliez pas on est confiné
mais en restant bien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain